so on the bonus show today we are going
to talk about steve bannon's conviction
on two counts of contempt of congress
but what i want to talk about here is
that even after this conviction and you
gotta say he is certainly acting with
conviction he went back on his program
and started talking about shock troops
deconstructing the government brick by
brick more coded language that sounds
very much like an insurrectious coup
steve bannon calls on four thousand
shock troops to deconstruct the
government brick by brick he's back with
more incendiary rhetoric against the
nation days after his contempt of
congress conviction
check out this clip and understand that
he's calling for treason again
and there are people who listen to this
guy
and who act based on what he says
and these are not
accidental phrases that he's using this
is all very specifically targeted to
have a particular impact on the people
that hear it take a listen to this
we're talking about a republican
democracy because essentially we have
taken on the model
of really davos and the chinese
communist party of an authoritarian
state undemocratic with institutions
that are not democratic now understand
that i we're going to listen to the
entire thing
but
this is one of those oh the democrats
are going to do voter fraud and really
they tried to steal an election they
didn't win
one of the principles of traditional
conservatism
is small government now we know that in
many ways they never really adhered to
it they're like small government but
let's decide who can get married small
government but let's decide what medical
procedures women can have okay we know
that it was bs all along
but while continuing to claim that they
are against authoritarianism
they are increasingly using government
as a way to achieve what they want
rather than allowing markets or public
opinion or culture or whatever to make
decisions they want
whenever they see something they don't
like
they want courts up to and including the
supreme court to just make decisions
that favor them we saw this when it came
to the 2020 election didn't win an
election well to start filing lawsuits
and get courts and judges in the supreme
court if you're lucky enough to decide
that you actually get to be president
anyway
when it comes to abortion ban ban pass a
ban get the supreme court to overturn
ban it at the state level ban it at the
federal level ban uh contraception uh or
access to it or or
standard access to it without a copay as
part of health insurance they
increasingly are the ones trying to use
state power to achieve their goals but
bannon insists that it's the left that
wants to do that
and state capitalism
now how do you combat that
you combat that by deconstructing you
have to take it apart brick by bricks
you know steve uh it gets my deplorable
blood going on a monday morning to hear
jonathan swann talk about a purge a
purge of the administrative state now of
course he means that to be an expose and
to be a hit on our movement we take it
exactly the opposite and wear it as a
badge of honor and it tells me that yes
uh jonathan swann recognizes that there
is a plan in place that this second
trump term is going to be far more
consequential than the first one and the
first one was quite consequential
article three i'm going to get um mike
and we're going to have a one hour
special
on the jonathan swan
axios articles i want everybody to
understand
deeply
exactly what we're doing here okay
exactly what's going on because you're
going to be part of it
and particularly want people to come
stepping forward and say hey i i want to
be one of those 4 000 shock troops or
there's going to be lots of other
opportunities lots of other
opportunities lots of opportunities for
treason want to be a shock troop and
what exactly shock troops do of course
is nebulous and uh he's calling for
treason again and the point here of
using the various euphemisms is for
plausible deniability right deconstruct
the administrative state okay well
that's just basically taking apart
centers of power in government by
eliminating departments and that doesn't
sound violent does it well though it's
not in and of itself but it's all part
of this idea that they need
shocking
action and when you talk about troops of
course you're alluding to force and
military force and weapons and all of
these different things this was a term
coined by steve steve bannon this is all
meant to keep them all ginned up and at
the ready to do whatever it is that you
need them to do and by them i'm talking
of course about the supporters the
patsies who end up
uh prosecuted right who end up
prosecuted after the january six riots
while donald trump flies around giving
speeches so uh one other clip that i
want to look at here and uh he's using
we're going to kill the administration
in the crib that's another phrase that
bannon loves to use we said we killed
this in the crib now we were just a
small part of it but remember we've been
maniacally focused
since we talked friends we're going to
kill this administration in the crib hey
i don't care if benny thompson doesn't
like that nancy pelosi doesn't like it
or who doesn't like it justin department
i don't care if you don't like it suck
on it
we're destroying this illegitimate
regime yeah sort of weird by the way
that people who claim to be pro-life you
talk about killing things in the crib as
if that's a good thing to do but let's
put that aside for a moment these are
extraordinarily dangerous and violent
ideas that's one side to this
but i also don't want to ignore the
likely cynical reality that there's a
fundraising aspect to this thing
somewhere
there there is almost certainly
some motivation
in this new plan
that bannon starts to talk about now uh
which which seems to be wrapped up with
what many are writing is an imminent
announcement of a 2024 candidacy by
donald trump there's probably some
fundraising element to it as well
notice also that at one previous point
in time steve bannon promised twenty
thousand shock troops now he's down to
four thousand maybe recruiting isn't
going particularly well but this is what
happens when you don't properly punish a
coup attempt and make sure that
everybody knows that even at the top
level there's going to be consequences
yes the patsies in the capital
they got arrested they're getting
charged some of them are going to prison
but if you don't punish the people at
the top level it's going to continue and
you will see it stop when either
the leaders are properly punished or the
coup succeeds and that latter option
would be very very bad and of course the
fear is with a 6-3 supreme court in your
favor
that the success of the coup will take
place in 2024 going into 2025. bannon's
dangerous bannon should be in prison but
even being in prison where he will
likely spend some time or jail we'll
find out about that his sentencing is in
october
he still will likely be able to wield
influence and one of the things judges
are supposed to do when they sentence
individuals
is consider whether they're remorseful
and consider whether they're likely to
break the law again
steve bannon is not remorseful and steve
bannon is openly saying he is going to
continue getting involved in all sorts
of of horrible things
uh he's itching to do more harm and he
should get the maximum sentence he'll
probably end up with a minimum which i
believe is 30 days as many of you know
i'm a busy person i don't always have
the exact correct nutritional plan for
my meals every single day and that's why
i also take a multivitamin and a couple
of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high-quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below